Okay. So one of the handy properties of memcached, and one of
the things that makes a difference from a normal data base is, it
stores everything in memory. That's why it's so fast because reading from
memory is very fast. Reading from disk can be very slow. Which, which
gives memcached a couple of properties. One is that it's fast. Two
is that if you restart memcached, you lose all your data. So it's
not durable. You know, if you have to restart that machine or
restart memcached, the data isn't on disk. It's just in memory, and it's,
and it's, and it disappears. So, you need to keep that in
mind, that memcached is really just for caching, not for storing permanent
data. Finally, the amount of data we can store in, in, in
a particular instance of memechached is limited by how much memory that machine
has. Or maybe you have a system of machines and your memcached
library is bouncing over them. You can still only store so much data.
So what happens when you try to store more data than there
is memory available? And let's do this in the form of a quiz.
Now, I know I haven't told you the answer to this, but see if you can figure
it out. One of these answers is correct,
and I'll explain after you give it a shot.